bueno
tras un leve respiro los casos en europa
vuelven a crecer para principios de
agosto el continente supera los 3
millones de contagios y las 200.000
muertes
las restricciones vuelven pero esta vez
ante el agotamiento de los ciudadanos se
desatan protestas ante la imposición de
nuevas medidas
las autoridades piden no bajar la
guardia
aquí en esta región y particularmente en
la zona del lille estamos viendo un
aumento de los datos de la epidemia que
debe llevarnos más que nunca a estar
extremadamente movilizados y atentos
a nuestro éxito del principio no debe
volvernos imprudentes el clima de verano
es bueno para todos pero no debe
llevarnos a ser descuidados en nuestra
lucha contra la pandemia porque podemos
ver estos días cuán incierta e inestable
es la situación no la pandemia no ha
terminado no se ha ido estamos en medio
de ella
pese a que los casos no paran de crecer
en el mundo un país de 1300 millones de
ciudadanos se convierte en el nuevo
epicentro
[Música]
un día supera a brasil y se convierte en
el segundo país con más casos de kobe 19
así que las principales conclusiones de
esta encuesta serológicas son que una de
cada 15 personas mayores de 10 años ha
estado expuesta al sars co2 la campaña
hacia las elecciones presidenciales se
reactiva en eeuu y donald trump ahora
tiene un culpable de la pandemia
mientras perseguimos a este futuro
brillante debemos responsabilizar a la
nación que desató esta plaga en el mundo
china
zaira
el 27 de septiembre el mundo supera el
millón de muertes a causa de la pandemia
de kobe 19
tras un caótico debate presidencial en
que su equipo de campaña no usó
cubrebocas en mi respeto a la distancia
el presidente de trump y su esposa tan
positivo
[Música]
esta noche la primera dama y yo hemos
dado positivo en el test de kobe 19
comenzaremos nuestro proceso de
cuarentena y recuperación inmediata
pasaremos esto juntos
tras una convulsa selecciones
presidenciales joe biden vence a donald
trump un resultado que algunos analistas
atribuyen a su manejo de la pandemia
el 8 de noviembre el mundo supera los 50
millones de casos y registra más de
1.200.000 muertes sin embargo un día
después un rayo de esperanza llega tras
meses de malas noticias
[Música]